okay so uh let's hear john
huh talk about uh lettuce coats
thank you for giving me this opportunity
to speak here
um i am going to present
about the uh some formalism and my point
of view of
towards the lattice one codes um it is
really
uh intimately related to the previous
talk
by vishwanath it's it's
deeply related to gap spaces how to
understand them
um and what phases are there in
especially
dimensions not not restricted to the two
dimensions
and uh this is a very counter well this
leads to
example a very counterintuitive nature
where the previous notions of the
topological order
where the published order is not really
defined but it's
characterized by set of properties for
instance ground c degeneracy on the
depending on the lattice topology
and the topology containment entropy
and those properties
do not really survive i mean they do not
really depend on one another
and i will try to be rigorous
what implies what and what can be go
wrong
and what remains true so since
my example in the end will be very
contradictive counterintuitive
i will try to be reversed as possible
although
using a very simple example of the
three-dimensional target code
let me just first start with i assume
that you're not
too familiar with the quantum codes in
the first place
so let me briefly review what the
quantum codes were
again what are the two things that you
don't want us to think of as the same
i will uh i will distinguish that and
well i'll i'll try to be specific
as i go
so let's let's not think about lattice
for a moment
and let me just
define the word the quantum code what
what is the code
well it's not something complicated it's
just the subspace
subspace of
subspace of some so many cubits that's
it
of course we it's not an arbitrary
subspace it has to be white uh
cleverly chosen so that it gives some
property of error correction
but i'm not going to talk about air
question at this time
one particular and most important class
of quantum codes is so-called stabilizer
code
or some some mathematicians would like
to call it additive code
but this terminology is more popular
although i like this one better
and this is a subspace of many qubit
humor space that is plus one
i get space
common
uh it is defined by the plus one item
you'll need some
of a commuting set of quality operators
by poly operators i mean
tensor products of polymetrics each each
polymetrics is acting on one single
qubit
well let me give you an example suppose
i have five students
and i suppose i introduce a
poly mattress answer
since i'm going to talk about only for
poly operators based
i will drop the stigma simply and just
play with the accents
fishing location um
um even
those four operators we can simply check
that each of them
is commuting with one another because uh
if i multi uh if i multiply
this direction then i will have zn x
the anti-commuting pair of powdery
mattresses
always come in as even numbers so they
always commute
so and so we can think of a common eye
and space of those operators
and we are left with some subspace
that is not non-trivial and
the operators that act on that common
eye in space
can be chosen to be a poly operator as
well
and in this particular case
they can be chosen this way you can
check that each operator commutes with
every
one of four operators and
themselves are anti-community therefore
they
they act as a non-trivial operator on
the on the code space
now this is always true and i i would
like you to remember this fact
for any stabilizer code there
exists a poly operator that can generate
the operator algebra
on the code space so in order to learn
the operator algebra how
how what's going on to learn on the code
space
only you need to study is poly operator
that's enough
but so the operator that x on the code
space
is called logical operators i assume
they determine the other one
they're just commenting over each other
right communicator of each other
well this logical operator is stabilized
they just
that we communicate as an algebra inside
so i see
this one determine the other one
logical operator alone does not
determine the codes
well instead of all logical operators
code entirely but one a pair of
representatives from that
logical operator can be in a very
different uh
different form for instance
so if i have a some some weight vector
in the code space
that is stabilized by by these operators
well the main stabilizer comes
comes for this reason since i'm talking
about phosphon eigenspace
naturally if i pick a vector in the code
space
and apply one of the stabilizers it will
give me
plus one eigenvalue which means it
stabilizes that
code vector
so this state
can be written as say
we call this s1
it can be written in that way because
well by definition
but this operator is different from the
original x
bar this is
although the the form is different the
action on the code space is identical
but one thing you you would you would
notice is
here are some identity operators which
means
in order to act on the code space i
don't have to act on all
qubits i have to pick a special set of
subset of qubits
and that will suffice to to obtain that
action
so this well this is a brief review of
what the stabilizer
code is in terms of coding theory people
are interested in how to pick
this set of stabilizers such that
among all representative all of logical
operators
the weight of the
number of operators that are not
identity
to be large as possible
because that is closely related to
aircrafting power now
let's go to um
uh oh yeah and one thing
that is very important in the in in
every stabilizer code
um the logical operator should act on
at least two or more qubits which means
if i
act on one single qubit the operation
will not
be reached into your code space
even though code space is non-trivial at
least there are two or more
wave vectors in the code space if
they will not be able to distinguish by
acting on a single qubit
in other words if you take the reduced
density matrix on a single qubit
of any good quantum code that will give
you identical
for every code vectors so
any stabilizer code comes with the
property of local indistinguishability
this property is actually shared with
any topological order system in the
previous talk ashwin talked about the
torah code and it
depicted the caricature of the wave
function where the
strings are fluctuating since the
strings are fluctuating if you look at
the
local reduced density metrics there's no
way to tell
which state you are in that is exactly
that property
so quantum code is is designed to be
designed to study locally in
distinguished states
so if i imagine some some physical
system
where the ground states degenerate or
not
especially in the general case if the
wave functions of that ground state
is has a property of local
indistinguishability then we can
formally think of it as a quantum code
although it may not be presented as a
stabilizer formalism but
it is some sort of quantum code so
let's get back to the uh let's approach
the problem in a
reverse direction instead of studying a
quantum code aspect of a real physical
system
we just study what phases matter can be
represented
using quantum codes especially the
stabilizer code where the
algebra is simple
so
this is my question that i would like to
address in this talk
so let me be more specific to the
setting
i imagine a system with a hamiltonian
that is given by some of poly operators
that acts on some geometrically local
subset of the whole lattice
and well i want to study i want to
restrict myself to the quantum code
setting the stabilizer code
that and i want this to be just all the
operators
uh i don't want to play with
all kinds of uh hamiltonian i want to
restrict to the simple setting which
means i
am imposing the conductivity condition
and most physical systems are
translation invariant
where so it doesn't really have to be
but
for simplicity i i impose
i impose the translation of variance
now it comes to the question of what
kind of ladder should i choose
uh there are well actually told us that
in three dimensions there are two
230 kinds of lattices it's
a lot but when i restrict myself to a
geometry local and i
slightly release my condition where the
locality means
i just mean that it should act on a
small set
not necessarily in the nearest
neighborhood interaction
with that relaxation all lattices are
not
important because when you talk about
lattice
the all the matter is a
what what lattice points are nearest
to another things
so i can simply
replace all my lattice with a simple
cubic lattice
the price i i have to pay is that for
each lattice site i have to allow
many qubits it would be the case that
single qubit
is placed on on the side so
of course since because of the
translation invariance the number of
qubits per side
will be will be the same at every sum
uh one one technical assumption here
is that i don't want to
be bothered with the frustration
so this is my setting
a frustration frame means that each term
is minimized at
the ground state
so now
uh let's investigate the familiar very
familiar torah code in detail
and i will develop some my own
calculation method
and replace some small parts of it and
will obtain three-dimensional model
if passport is frustrating
you already assume it can use right
well that's something frustrating
what phase does it matter is
i want to characterize what the
ground states the hamiltonians of this
form
that what that are what's the relation
to the ground state
and the stabilizer code that they're in
that
well i simply put i'm just classifying
all phases
matter whose hamiltonian is in that form
that's my call what does it mean to be
realized by a stabilizer phone
well it's um
there's a simple mapping between the
stabilizer between the code being
the one eigenvalue of all stabilizers
and
that code being the ground state the
ground space of
a local homophobia is there a uniqueness
or anything or
yeah it's it's just projection on the on
the
on the one i think today okay
is it okay for you yes thank you
since i'm i'm assuming it's translation
in variance my target will be defined at
the square letters
strict square letters it won't be an
arbitrary graph
so as usual each edge
is associated with a single qubit and
there are
two interaction terms
this is not plus sign it's just that
so each blockhead is acted upon by this
black cat operator and each vertex there
is a corresponding
so-called star operator consists of
sigma x as a product of sigma x
any question for this notation
should be clear
so let's well let me let me first answer
how many ground states are there you
will all know that on the taurus you
there's a there are four but let me let
me explicitly calculate that
like i told you before on the every
stabilizer code there exists a poly
operator
that uh that that generates the operator
out around the code space which means
all i have to do to figure out the
number of ground states
i have to figure out what poly operator
really acts
on the code space so suppose i
i just flip well i
i i start i start with the with the
arbitrary code vector the ground state
and then suppose i act
by sigma z at one end
what is the energy of this state
according with respect to this
hamiltonian
all i have to do is measure these
operators
which means i apply some well
p is one of the star or pocket and
see what the what what eigen value it is
if p is eight pluck it up here it
obviously commutes
so it will be like this
and by definition
he stabilizes the code state which means
this term does not pick up any energy
however when p is a star operator that
that happens to act
on this star that there is a sigma x
operator here
that anti-commutes with p in that case i
will pick a minus sign
well again he will stabilize this i i'm
left with a minus
which means i pick up energy
a unit energy from this hamiltonian such
a
star operator appears at the two
locations here
and there let me throw in more operators
now all you have to do is to find the
terms in the hamiltonian that
anti-commutes with that operator
well it will appear here here
in here well i
i
well operator here really actually
commutes because it end commits here
there even number of positions but i can
think of that as a
combination of two minus signs that
cancels so i would like to just put the
two
dots and count the number of dots
modular two
that's more convenient well this is
simple calculation i don't have to
introduce any new notation for it but
for the sake of later
generalization let me do it
algebraically
so i would like to actually
express the positions of dots and
operator
in a in a nice way so the input
so here you see i throw in some operator
to the ground state
and i obtain the positions of
excitations
the positions of a star or clock head
that is violent
so it means that
i the input is list of operator
coordinates where should i put pick
operators
so it would be like if i put
this to be the origin zero comma zero
and this position is one comma zero
horizontal
and this operator is one comma zero
vertical
and that is uh zero comma one
vertical
so i this is input theta operator
position
the output is the positions of
dots in this case
um two comma zero
one comma zero there are two dots at the
one comma zero
and one from one
zero one zero comma two
that's my output so my hamiltonian
function is like a program
i throw in coordinates and i obtain
coordinates back
how would you program it in the future
i don't want to work with the
coordinates so i
introduced a trick to to
to express those coordinates in the
exponents
i mean
y one
and i just well this looks like a
monomial
so i just put placeholder
plus sign it doesn't really mean
anything it just
separates two monomials all right
i want to stop just because i understand
that you will be using this a lot
um so i'd understand the h v and v
in the in the locations of disease
the the second z in the middle has both
h and v note
so this one yeah for example what's
what's its coordinate
this uh well i'm associating edge with
the
uh so i'm associating the edge in this
fashion
vertical edge is always associated with
the
vertex in the south and
horizontal as edge i associate vert
vertex on the left
okay
and well the same track can be done here
too
uh x square well let me omit the
zero because this is
x x
x y y
y square but
actually this plus sign makes sense
if i compute everything modular two
because i told you
that i put a virtual pair of
black dots to express the overall plus
sign
which originates from the cancellation
of two minus signs
that is reflected here if i do the
polynomial addition
modulo 2.
just erase them now my program
accepts this polynomial with a special
character as e h or ev
and outputs a single polynomial
since my system is translation invariant
i can shift everything to arbitrary
position
but here position mean a translation
means that i
add certain numbers to all of the
coordinates
which corresponds to multiplication of
monomial of some exponents here
and distribute them so
just to verify your notation these are
locations of
locations of sigma z operator that are
applied onto
a ground state okay so you're just using
sigma z
yeah uh generalizations of sigma x would
be easy
just let me focus on sigma set
so the overall map is simply a matrix
multiplication
you see this single term
is mapped to this polynomial
and the other term is mapped to
this one this one is mapped to here
whenever i have e h i multiply by
1 plus x whenever i have ev
i multiply by 1 plus y
and that's the rule applies here too
so if i uh make if i
express this as a column matrix by
writing
like
upper row represents eh and the lower
row
ev that's that's input
and all i have to do is multiply
these two polynomials well this is the
pure
the usual matrix multiplication
including sigma x or matrix gets a lot
large because you have to express
whether it is sigma x or sigma set
so i have a matrix
this explains all calculation i have
done there
whatever poly algorithm gave me i
express them
uh using some column vector of this form
with the positions including index
exponents
multiply this matrix the result will be
the positions of excitations
now get back to the original question
what
what are the poly operators that acts on
the ground space
those are precisely operators that does
not create any extension
because by definition it should map the
ground state to another ground state
which means if i apply this map it
should result in a zero
so i really compute the kernel of this
matrix
over the polynomial algebra
well subject to the boundary condition
like
x to the l is really doing nothing which
means
one into y by l times
is really one
not all solutions of this
kernel is going to work because
we have seen here uh see one logical
operator can have
many representative it could be
expressed in this way
or in that way they are really the same
operator
and by definition these are commuting
with
all with one another which means if i
plug in
poly operator that happens to be a term
here
to the epsilon matrix i will
automatically get zero
so i have to mult out those trivial
solutions
and those trivial solutions also have
a matrix representation
can you see this
so it's it's not very difficult to see
that
the image of this matrix
actually generates all trivial solutions
of this
so the logical operator
is really
it's really this it has one-to-one
correspondence with the non-trivial
representative
operator and one element in this set
and now um so yeah
that's called sigma there now yes that's
called sigma
so here input is a two component vector
because it's four by two so you
apply all possible polynomials here
and obtain a set of polynomials
that is expressed in this way and that
forms the image
i have i have transformed the
representation of the torah code using
just two matrices
well in fact the two matrices are not
distinct one
you can obtain one from the other one
uh if the formula is just a
transposition enveloped by a simple
row operation
do you work with a wrong polynomial or
you convert y to the minus one
into y to the l yeah i well i should
have said it's the lower polynomial
precisely but
do you think something like that would
also work for codes with higher
dimensional
units i'm going to that okay
so so um
yeah and this is non-zero
only if
uh you can you can actually see that
this
is only non-zero when you impose
boundary conditions
without this actually this
object and that is the same
let's see that well this is a actually
direct sum of two
block diagonal things so let me just
focus on this sub matrix
so
if i have
suppose i multiply some polynomial by
this matrix
and suppose i obtain one zero
without boundary condition then it means
a
they are the same i'm working modular
two so
sine is never important but
well polynomial has a unique
factorization
which means one plus x should divide
b times 1 plus y
but 1 plus x does not divide 1 plus y
therefore it should divide b
likewise 1 plus y should divide a
and turn because of equality you must
have
this relation then
well my original variable
becomes
time c which is indeed
generated by this portion
so without boundary condition this is
really zero
what does that mean physically it means
this is essentially local
indistinguishability because
if i have some operator that acts on the
ground space
and suppose the operator is supported on
some finite region
as long as it's finite and does not
touch the boundary
it is expressed as a some polynomial of
finite degree
right and if i plug in into the epsilon
i obtain the zero
i should obtain zero but
the calculation says that those operator
are actually generated by this which
means
it is generated by the terms in the
hamiltonian
and the terms in hamiltonian is by
definition x trivially on the ground
space
so the logicals goes the conclusion is
whenever you have a finite operator that
does not create
any explanation it is expressed in terms
of
trivial operators there's no operator
that can act
non-tribute on the ground space
so having this object zero without
boundary condition
implies local indistinguishability of
grams
now let's make an observation
in this calculation i didn't really use
any fact about two dimensions
all i needed is that one plus x does not
divide one plus y
and vice versa so let me replace with
arbitrary
polynomial
so every question so the code is really
sitting in that map right this one plus
exposure
yes that's that the term is fully it's
called but you're saying this is a
general property
you're showing here explicitly but this
fact that if you if you don't get the
boundary
you have to have to get the boundary
conditions in there in order for this to
be nonzero right yeah
let me just compute the first model
homology of the horrors
it's essentially the representation of
cellular tessellation
just says the first one of the sphere is
zero correct
but this is the representation of what
representation
presentation um
it's not really representation of some
something something more algebraic it's
just uh
oh well technically it's a
representation of the translation group
but i don't think that interpretation
helps anyway
so suppose i had an absolute map with
where the bar means that i replace every
variable with this inverse
well that's that's a technical reason
but it works
and suppose i have
just co-prime two polynomials then
whenever
whatever i throw in i will get locally
distinguished for ground states
and well it doesn't have to be
polynomials in two variables it could be
any variables like just
pointed out this enables generalization
to average
the number of spatial dimensions is
equal to the number of variables
i missed the argument about the locals
okay
so where do you get the local properties
local property is encoded in the fact
that
any local operator is represented by
finite polynomial
it's not a series the degree has to be
some number
indeed without the condition you can
multiply like
if you plug in that you get zero so
so so let me chose a
particular two polynomials
there is no particular reason that i
chose something symmetric
but the calculation
later becomes nicer than i chose this
well
the only thing important here is that
there are gcps
and using this you can actually figure
out what the hamiltonian was
that and the answer is the so-called
cubic code
so
thank you
um well physically this is crazy normal
it has a heat
body interaction and it has a
very strong and isotropy so i'm not
very sure about the physical relevance
of this model but it's theoretically
interesting
um so i just changed the oneplus x with
the
with the simple point in the
three-dimensional model
what's special about this
question the the way you choose this
g and f the bar is because of things
have to commute
very sensitive
so this is really uh a
this really uh sigma z
uh where the coordinates are inserted
according to this diagram
product of eight poly matrices and i
means
there's no
okay so but so the dimensionality if you
want a high dimensional code you'd have
to have a higher degree poland you know
we're never
did you just translate your code into
this formula
well it's uh it's
it went backwards i i observed this at
the very last stage
so what's special about this um we the
strange thing happens in the excitation
as well as underground speed degeneracy
but let's focus on excitation first
well precisely because the absolute map
here
is designed to capture all aspects of
excitations
i throw in poly operators and epsilon
tell me
where their stations are
six
um so let's start with uh
let's focus on this element only
and let's focus on the uh
vector v where vector is
like some something here and strictly
zero there
so i'm ignoring this g part
suppose i start with one which means i
i introduce the single sigma z at the
origin
then epsilon v tells me that
this is my excitation
well exponents represents the
coordinates so it means
there's uh there's extension at the
origin one
wanted the one unit to the x direction
so there are four four x def stations
arranged in this fashion
well since this is polynomial set so let
me replace
one with this f
will vary this what happens
if it epsilon tells me i have to square
it
but modular 2 any coefficient 2 is equal
to 0.
so i just do the
seemingly round calculation which is
only valid modular two
well that means the distance between
x stations has been doubled
right let me do one more one more step
uh z request
v2 f square f
literal polynomial you just expect you
plug in
that expression yes okay sure
well epsilon v2 is
f times f squared f
which is f2 before well 4 is the power
of 2.
so
i have 2 to the 2 this is
you get another doubling of a separation
between excitations
you can keep doing it you just plug in
uh
vn f2d 2 to the n
minus 1 all the way to f
then this this will give us uh
extensions that are separated by two to
the n plus one
but how does this software look like
so can you interpret your excitation as
a tetrahedron
yeah if you can so that's the shape
so let's figure out this expression
first well f
uh one is one
f is
minus one f square f is
every time you know like the first one
you put in one z error then you put in
f which is these errors on these sides
and then you see what you have to do
well yeah i'm mixing two things but the
mixing is possible because i'm using
polynomial there's no ambiguity
so let's look at in terms of coordinates
this is a point and whenever i multiply
this
i i distribute them in a certain way
by distance one but the next stage
each such configuration is copied four
times
that are separated by distance two away
and in the end
i will get some fractal
it it's a convenient way to see well
generate
some self-similar structure this
particular combination
here i'm sorry what is you're trying to
generate the structure with what
properties
i'm not i'm not going to understand what
is it uh
so i was well my original
intention was to have a configuration
where the
excitations are arbitrary far away
and this is a one particular way of
getting that in configuration
and now i'm interested in what operator
does that does the job
uh um well
i'm not sure if if it is intuition but
uh uh
you can actually generalize to into
well it doesn't have to be two by four
matrix
it can be t by some even number matrix
um well cube is not that important
let's do the calculation first but this
formalism came after you came up with
the code right so you search for the
code in very different ways
yeah i did
well yeah anyway here in this particular
example
it was possible to isolate a single
excitation from the rest
by arbitrary large distance and the
operator
that creates that configuration has some
self-similarity
but surprisingly this is essentially the
only way you can separate
a single charge
any isolated excitation
always appears as a
as a vertex of some of some fractal
this may not be a very trivial statement
and it's
it's one of the theorem i have proved
of course you have to define what the
fractal means here but
uh essentially any isolated oxidation
there exists some certain polynomial
like f here
and when you combine the f in this way
then you are left with the
target excitation for that
so your excitation has a symmetry
between z2 plus z2
survive to the parabola right you just
you just scale this up
you know you have a tetrahedron we have
a z2 rotation
of the two axis oh
oh uh well the that that statement
does not require that symmetry but i'm
saying your excitation you have this
symmetry
where you go as large as you want it's
always there
this statement is true whenever when the
matrix system is large
it doesn't have to be in this form but
if you
remember the setting where the whole
hamiltonian is translation invariant and
written
in terms of holy operators
and in particular the usual notion of
string
is a it's a special case of fractal
because
line resembles itself you know but i
don't
i don't understand what you said
whenever that matrix is large you have
this statement
oh uh so so
well the fact that the fact that there
are two rows
reflects the fact that there are two
types of
interactions in the hamiltonian the star
and pocket but in principle you could
have
as many interactions as you like
so can you how general is this can you
achieve the same thing
not in 3d but in general it holds in
arbitrary dimensions
as long as you have no general graph
it's cubic lattice
hypercubic lattice so the translation
group
should be some product of images
what happened in 2d if you just pick f
equals more plus
x well let's do the calculation okay
uh so when f is one plus x
then
so this is a 0.22 point well let me
you can just expand it it just
uh
so the number of term matters
if you have two terms in it then the
fractal it generates is a string
but if you have more than that then it
becomes uh
so i think i'm over time already but
two dimension is very special you can
introduce
co-prime polynomial using two variables
arbitrarily
that you can find you can show that it
is
after certain local units transformation
and some core screening
you will end up with the usual torah
code
that's very special property of two
dimensions
uh no well this formula isn't
straightforwardly generalized to the q
bits with prime dimensions
so it has little to do with the being
you're using qubit
but really two dimensions matters
so i have another question where it's
related to the top at the read kit
so if you have a condition and say i
hold a code where
if i have an error with high weight
beyond some
number then the syndrome is has highway
skills with
with that with with the weight of the
error is that a condition
that you can put into this
no i understand you didn't put a
condition here but can you put it into
this formula
so because it depends on the you know
i want the code where the the weight of
you know
the the code is such that if i have an
error of weight
k and k is sufficiently large
that the syndrome also has weight
k or scale oh luckily locally testable
codes yes
um well
if you are sick with the lattice
settings polynomials
if you're a stick with the lattice and
if you consider family of codes
parametrized by the system size
then that will not be achievable
okay well simply because in the in the
lattice setting
well you can just stack the stabilizers
in the hamiltonian
such that it occupies certain
non-trivial volume
and it will not cause any syndrome at
all
of course it's not an error but no it's
on error
uh
um
the statement i i i made was just big
fixed dimension no okay so
you have to have dimension yeah but
because this formula is
very nice and compact so maybe we can
address this question yep
possibly trying to understand what this
physically means to say that
an isolated excitation is the vertex or
reflector
so if i i'm trying to have a certain
separation between my excitations
does it mean i need to get the number of
excitations i generate
scales in some way with the separation
uh
right so usually we thought of a point
like station to be attached to a string
that's the only issue but the cubicle
showed that
it's not necessarily the case but then
the natural question is what else
could it be but this says
that that's pretty much all in the
fixed dimensional setting so if it is
real fractal
then um it is not that there is a
potential between two charges
the charges are decombined however in
the process of making that configuration
you should go over
some high energy state
so you can still just get a pair of
isolated charges
not a pair pair is not allowed
and another statement that i want to
well advertise is that this three
dimensions
is also special because in three
dimensions
well two dimensions all fractals are
string essentially
but in three dimensions you must have
certain fractal
well it can be it can be some uh string
like
but uh like in the
before for the tutorial code you don't
really have any point like once you all
you have little like ones
but that does not happen in three
dimensions
include here thank you